la zone c est actuellement en vacances
scolaires et même pendant cette période
de confinement les services de
l'éducation nationale à travail en vue
de la rentrée afin d'assurer la
continuité pédagogique est d'autant
qu'un objectif a été est désormais fixé
par le président de la république
rouvrir progressivement les écoles à
partir du lundi 11 mai bonsoir charline
avenel vous êtes la rectrice de
l'académie de versailles merci d'être
avec nous une question déjà sur ce sujet
ce qu'on connaît les modalités cette
reprise dans l'académie de versailles ou
est ce encore trop tôt pour pour les
fixes s le président de la république et
le ministre de l'éducation nationale se
sont exprimés il s'agit d'un retour qui
sera progressif et donc l'ensemble des
conditions qui devront être mises en
place
que ce soit la temporalité que ce soient
les modalités que ce soient les
modalités sanitaires les modalités
d'accompagnement pédagogique et bien
tout cela est en cours de préparation et
est en discussion il y à une
consultation qui vient de s'ouvrir hier
auprès du ministre avec les principaux
partenaires les familles les lycées à
les organisations syndicales et donc
réponses à toutes vos questions à toutes
celles que les parents se posent dans
quinze jours le délai de quinze jours et
qui a été effectivement fixé par le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer on aura l'occasion d'en
savoir plus d'ici quelques jours donc
pendant ces vacances scolaires un peu
spécial un peu le dire en cette de
confinement des stages de soutien
scolaire ont été mises en place au sein
de l'académie de versailles
ils ont débuté depuis mardi comment
comment cela s'est organisée j'en
appelle alors absolument nous avons mis
en place des stages de soutien scolaire
d'abord je veux je veux commencer à dire
que les vacances sont les vacances donc
nos personnels avaient besoin d'être en
vacances nos élèves aussi est donc
vraiment l'idée là c'est d'être en
vacances même si nous sommes tous nous
sommes confinés
mais le confinement amène également de
déséquilibre des iniquités qui
malheureusement se creuse en dépit
d'efforts qui sont colossaux faits par
nos enseignants pour rester en contact
avec les élèves qui sont les plus
fragiles
et puis animé
leur leurs pratiques pédagogiques et
donc nous avons souhaité pendant cette
deuxième semaine de vacances apporter à
ces élèves qui sont donc les plus
fragiles les plus en difficulté 6h02 de
renforcement avec des enseignants qui
sont des enseignants volontaires qui se
font sur des thématiques qui sont très
très central comme le français les
mathématiques pour les plus pour les
plus jeunes par exemple et sur la bosse
base du volontariat pour les enseignants
de manière très personnalisés les jeunes
sont dans des groupes qui ne dépasse pas
plus de 6 de plus de 6 élèves dans les
yvelines
puisque ces départements qui vous
intéressent tout particulièrement
on a cette semaine un peu plus de dix
mille élèves qui sont qui sont ainsi
mobilisés et donc pour voilà pour ces
stages de soutien scolaire
parlons pour terminer de la continuité
pédagogique c'était la promesse affichée
par l'éducation nationale au début de
cette pub de confinement l'assuré
perdurer un set cette continuité
certains avaient émis justement des
réserves en raison de la fracture
numérique
la difficulté pour certains élèves
d'accéder à des cours en ligne quel
bilan vous faites vous sur sur cette
première moitié en tout cas de la
continuité pédagogique qui a été mise en
place et bien le bilan il est positif
parce que en quelques jours
l'ensemble de notre communauté s'est
mise à faire l'école tout à fait
autrement par exemple dans le premier
degré c'est-à-dire les écoles primaires
on a créé en l'espace de deux jours
l'équivalent de 1700 blog pour que les
enseignants puissent mettre leurs
supports les ateliers de lecture des
moules le programme d'une journée les
petits exercices que les élèves font
donc vraiment il ya eu un virage
colossal qui a été pris très vite
évidemment on a été confronté au sujet
de la fracture numérique et donc nous
avons redéployé avec l'aide des
collectivités locales des tablettes des
ordinateurs vis-à-vis des publics qui
n'en avaient pas aujourd'hui se met en
place le dispositif de la poste qui
acheminent
encore aujourd'hui du matériel
pédagogique vers les élèves au total
on a redistribué plus de 3000 outils et
on ne va pas s'arrêter là puisque
l'effort va se poursuivre et notamment
maintenant que le dispositif de la poste
est mise en place
enfin évidemment ça ne suffit pas à
couvrir l'ensemble des besoins et
surtout à rester vraiment bien accroché
avec les evènes ce que nous faisons ce
que les enseignants font ce que les
surveillants font et bien c'est être au
téléphone avec avec les élèves les
appeler une deux fois par semaine
vraiment garder ce contact si essentiel
dans un lien vraiment très personnalisé
pour s'assurer que nous restons avec un
niveau d'accrochage de contact suffisant
avec les élus et donc cette continuité
pédagogique qui va durer avec la rentrée
rentrée en tout cas en confinement 1 qui
se déroulera à partir de lundi merci
d'avoir été avec nous charline
avesnelles merci monsieur et je rappel
merci et je rappelle que vous êtes
la rectrice de l'académie de versailles